[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I guess I'll just call you guys up one
by one here so since Benzinger all by
yourself over here been Tanner who is
the CTO and found co-founder of Kaggle
then come on up I think many of you guys
know Kaggle here we've got vajay Gil
from Salesforce SVP of engineering at
Salesforce and also an alumnus of Google
Microsoft and AOL and we've also got my
good friend Tim Shaw skip Flagg CTO and
co-founder at skip lag and before that
one of the top engineers working at
LinkedIn so guys thanks for coming great
to see we've got some folks here eerily
waiting the happy hour so we're going to
do our best to make sure we keep the
pace brisk we will leave time later on
for some Q&A from the audience but I
really wanted to start out with one
question we talked a little bit about in
the green room which is you know data
engineering didn't exist ten years ago
many of us were doing stuff like that
but we didn't know we'd have a name for
it and I thought I would start by asking
you guys to share your own personal
anecdote for the gnarliest data
engineering pipeline you ever worked on
and why so I'm going to start with I see
Sam you leaning in here let's just hear
a story from your background about a
gnarly data engineering pipeline and why
so when I first got into data
engineering it was working at LinkedIn
and when I started we had this people
you may know system which as the name
implies recommended people that you want
to connect with in your network
it was kind of an N squared problem so
everyone on the site you want to map to
everyone else on the site and when I
started there the product hadn't updated
the site for six months because they
just couldn't get it to run they were
just trying trying trying any bit T
equals scripts
I remember we printed out like the data
flow diagram and we needed to get a
plotter so I figure out how things
actually worked eventually we did move
it to hit do but actually got it running
and so that was like the gnarliest and
then most challenging data problem that
I ever worked on so that's what happens
when you let that assign
just build products right you end up
with that there's sequel scripts you
know that don't even with tables that
are all over the place exactly
with all variables in one one letter
variable later he did you did confound
your company with I think the guy who is
responsible for that so that obviously
something good happen there right
exactly
pizzicato accent you may know vajay so
might let me draw this my data problems
are more around data fidelity and
reproducibility of the pipelines so
thankfully most Morden systems can work
and work at scale however the
engineering problems that we run into
previous jobs and so on so forth is are
you getting the right data where are
they coming from are the data complete
is the pipeline reproducible a concrete
example is that we had an old log
shipping system where the processes
could write to disk and then
periodically from a cron job it would
package up those log files and this is
like app log syslog whatever and then
FTP them over to a collecting point and
then you would decompress and process
them we switch that to a Kafka based
system so you a quote unquote quasi
real-time the problem was of course so
first of all the reason we switch to
Kafka was we didn't want processes
having arbitrary write permission to
disk because that kills non-repudiation
if any process can arbitrarily write to
a file on disk
you can't repudiate so you can repudiate
what's in the log stream so to prevent
non-repudiation we like oh we have to
switch to an in-memory thing where data
lineage is marked on ingress by which
process put the data in tagged it and
then send it over so the first thing was
you want to remove access to disk and
only use a single process authorized to
spell to disk in case the buffers can
contract to stream and the problem with
this was that the periodicity of the ftp
pipeline was on the order of like hours
so as a result even if processes were
lagging or they were out of order the
the periodicity the window would closed
and you would actually get all the data
that you wanted for the period kind of
collapse so when we started doing
I reasoned between the real-time data
and the lagging data of course there was
like discrepancies because at scale
nothing is ever consistent so this is
one of the things you have good learned
right and you are running into Six Sigma
problems every day and so reconciling
all of that moving the windows around
which kind of led us to the gap theorem
of of data consistencies like an
accuracy velocity and volume pick two
that I think was the biggest learning
because we thought hey we put it in
Kafka awesome will do all real time and
years later finding or something working
I heard a story that Facebook at one
point decided to move all their logging
to real time they had this big internal
initiative and then they ultimately were
like this is way too hard and it went
back to that been gnarliest data
engineering problem you've worked on
there's a lot of differences here I
think you guys hey why don't you do this
okay
take two wow that's a lot better yeah
okay so we've touched a ton of different
problems at Kaggle so this is actually
really tough one to pick um one thing
that a lot of people actually don't know
about cackled is ambition to
competitions and all of the other work
that we've done we actually spent a lot
of time working with the oil and gas
industry and what we have on the
starfish seemed like a really
fascinating machine learning problem how
do you get all the data that you can and
train machine learning models to
identify here's a good spot to drill for
oil and here's how you should drill it
because it seems like it's machine
learning models on top of machine
learning models on top of machine
learning models for first like develop a
geophysical model of how the earth works
and then for the likelihood of world
being there and then how the drilling
would work on top of that seems like a
really fascinating problem then we
started doing a bit deeper in it
and I'm one of the operating principles
so we keep it Kaggle is other work that
we should do should be in to end
reproducible with a single command just
because there's a lot of different
benefits you get from focusing on
reproducibility and making it easy for
you to make one change in one part of
the pipeline and see a propagate through
or have a colleague come and work on it
as well so we started applying this
principle to this problem and start
getting some data
sets and we discovered that data was
incoming Kevin nice clean databases but
it says was coming to us in the form of
thousands and thousands of PDF documents
have been saved in different formats for
hundreds and hundreds of Excel documents
that are dumped on a different server to
us so we end up with a incredibly gnarly
like 2,000 line make file they call it
off to a bunch of stuff make files to
try combining all these results together
and we spent probably about ninety five
percent at a time on parsing PDFs and
pulling the debt relevance data out of
PDFs new clean and reproducible we had
about five percent of the part in the
part that we found super interesting for
the machine learning part and that for a
loved it for machine learning problems
that type of ratio isn't very uncommon
yeah I once had to get disks from a
client that had like an old Oracle
database format on it and figure out
whether there is like big ambien or
small Indian there was I almost I think
I was left my job and that when that
happened okay so we set the table with
some gnarly data engineering pipelines
I'm going to go to Sam because we did
work at LinkedIn you guys talked
obviously thought a lot about teams and
people and we were talking earlier and
you made the point that you know when
you're building out we're doing data
engineering and one of the lessons
learned from a decade of data
engineering that's the name of our panel
here today is thinking about how that
engineers work in the organization so
I'd love just maybe even specifically
your own experience how does it work at
LinkedIn and how do you think it ought
to work if any differently in the modern
era yeah I think one of the big changes
from like kind of then and now is the
way most or data teams are structure or
the way that I think a team should be
structured so historically what happened
was you had data engineers kind of doing
a lot of ETL you know transferring
things from various systems and making
them you know consumable by data
scientists and that's very much like a
thankless kind of job it's very
difficult it's hard to understand
because you have to horizontally
understand the business to know how are
you going to transform that
and then the other hand you had data
scientists who maybe you know knew some
sequel or some MATLAB but they couldn't
really take their ideas and put them
into production right they need two data
engineers to help and that was very
difficult and unhappy from both ends of
the spectrum because data engineers
didn't want to work on the ass end of
projects and data scientists really had
trouble like getting data and like
actually taking their ideas and putting
them into production I think what's
happened now is a couple of things the
on the data engineering side the tools
and the frameworks are gotten a lot
better especially from like the various
cloud providers that it's easy or easier
to kind of go spin up data pipelines and
get that stuff going and the frameworks
are gotten easier so you can plug kind
of your transformers in there and then
on the data science side what's happened
is that most data scientists is now kind
of know Python that's become like the
minimum standard for you know because
all of numpy tend to put all the various
libraries there so you have these data
scientists who have almost become ml
engineers on one end and then the
frameworks have gotten much easier so
what now you can do is data scientists
can no more work end-to-end and kind of
own their ideas so you get a lot more
iteration velocity through autonomy data
engineers work on scaling systems and
work more on frameworks and horizontal
tools and that's like I think a better
way to structure data teams today I'm
going to pop to them because it's like a
little bit about tool change and then I
want to talk about security and access
but then given so you nodding when you
said you know data scientists are
learning more getting a little bit more
savvy what if you know what have you
seen in terms of the tool chain and how
it's changed in terms of people who are
building you know whether they're data
scientists who need to do some data
engineering work what have you seen the
evolution of the tool chain in the last
couple of years
present make differences if we look at
the history of the casual community it's
kind of scroll back in time to five or
six years ago MATLAB would have been
where the most common language is on
goggle which penetrate a lot of
universities and thus a lot of people
have you know learned it in universities
but it's a terrible language from a data
engineering standpoint or to like think
about how to build a scalable system and
they're worried it's great if you love
pointers
and then where the things that we've
really seen emerge over the past five or
six years it's really twofold first as a
base layer Python and R have really
started to dominate the ecosystem in
terms of base playing which is that
almost every order everyone is becoming
familiar with and even if they don't
know deeply can operate and use ap is
that are available in those languages
and then secondly the APA is have become
gone from almost non-existent or
proprietary to very very
well-put-together for Jewel's like I'm
secular and which lets you with a couple
commands trained against 100 machine
learning models and evaluate those to
things like piano and caressed and
tensorflow and that kind of massive
explosion of deep learning frameworks
over the past one to two years it's
really changed from trying to write like
the pain of writing in neural network or
still getting in the old network to work
has gone from like a massive team that a
five-year research project for specific
application to it's something that you
can do over a 30-minute coffee while
you're waking up in the morning so you
know one of the things the values we've
seen as toolchains have gotten better is
democratization of access to data inside
organizations so there's a lot more
self-serve opportunities when someone
can go and write a sequel query on their
Hadoop cluster with hive versus having
the right MapReduce which is what it was
back in back in the day when I was a
young lad so I guess you Jay you're
talking about you know how access and
security there are considerations that
you've had to think about tell us a bit
about how you know how does access
security authorization has this factored
into the data engineering work that
you're doing at Salesforce so I think to
build on what both of my panelists said
one of the things that is happening is
that we've switched from point to point
apps where like the data end result and
the starting of the of the where the
data came from was the spoke to that
particular output or that particular
business function so in some ways we
started from where like you had security
through obscurity in the sense that you
needed to know
what business process was putting what
data where to actually craft a query
that would be relevant or could be
potentially dangerous in some ways right
so most people it was too hard to do so
you have this kind of like nice safe
comforting thing where like if somebody
really want to do they could but mostly
they dint how many people remember using
telnet to access servers holy crap okay
I rest my case
right now anybody using telnet today
that would be like a massive violation
right fireable offense yeah 10 years ago
15 years ago tell it was the only thing
for the most part right so the same
thing is now happening we're now we are
getting to like platform ization of data
so that starts where to make data easy
to consume what we've done is we've
built these data discovery tools for
example we run these bad jobs that will
automatically create and Co datasets
that are relevant we have good data
lineage now well most people don't some
do but you yeah you see where I'm going
we're going to have some idea what data
lineage
looks like even though most people don't
implement it so at least we can now have
data dictionaries and data discovery
tools will tell you data catalogs what
data are where and what where they came
from right so now you can actually do a
lot more damage with for example
exfiltration of PII so on and so forth
because now you have very nicely curated
data sets that are available and there's
even a pointer to what lives where all
right dangerous time to be so we spend a
lot of time now thinking around how to
kind of put access on them obfuscation
of certain fields for example if you
don't have access to those particular
fields but you want like for example
anonymized cohorts or more specifically
we take those data sets out of
consideration if you run a query if you
don't have access to and managing and
manipulating that tying that back to sso
or LDAP Active Directory control groups
is actually a spear lis significant data
engineering problem on its own from a
security and Trust perspective and of
course then there are things like
encryption on desk encryption at the
file level or on the table level that I
think will become more and more germane
as these datasets get larger and larger
because I think now from a corporate
perspective a lot of the value is in
data and we've seen like people actively
looking to exfiltrate data sets because
now the data you can actually do a fair
amount of damage or X well trade IP let
me ask a quick follow-up or maybe I'll
start with Sam on the you know when it
comes to you talking about encryption of
systems and access you had a very
bespoke your federated I guess is one
nice way to call it on silos might be a
more denigrating way but one of the I
guess the questions is you know at a lot
of organizations edge processing versus
centralized what did you guys see
LinkedIn in terms of was there you know
shift over the years towards having more
centralized processing of log files and
and infant use signals coming from
different systems or was it more
decentralized or did that pendulum kind
of swing in different ways while you
were there and the lar on the question
of standards you know you talk to the
jury about how there were no standards
everyone was doing their own thing how
did you see that of all that at Lincoln
while you guys built your in front from
when we were able to like centralize the
data and ask you create a data lake that
I think the value actually came out of a
has been off the whole time have you
guys okay good okay I think the value
actually came from when we were able to
centralize the data and create that data
lake where we were able to join
different data sets together that
actually was provided the value I think
is a lot of the pop that you saw with
the data products and obviously the
tension became there is how do you
actually deal with that in a privacy
kind of preserving manner so what we
ended up doing was ETL and things like
that we're all separated so you made
sure the data sets were actually
separated but they were available why I
like the same singular kind of API our
system and we basically layered access
controls on top of that there was never
really at least we never found a really
great solution so we made it really easy
but there was always access controls on
top of things and so it always became
this like tension between being able to
move that and be able to get
data and then having things kind of
locked down and that's just the policy
thing that we kind of played with over
the years but I don't fortunately don't
have like a great solution of how you
balance the attention there so the day
you tweeted out sometime in the last
couple of years and I quote the first
job for strong AI will be data cleanup
then you are a guy who's worked in the
world of AI and machine learning at
Kegel what have you guys seen for the
prospects of AI to help us data
engineers if anything we're to have
hosting so me cowgrill competitions in
growing a large community we've inspired
a large community to think it's a really
good idea to try optimizing the process
of trading machine learning models and
like value during the heuristic
operations on top of that made trading a
model well selecting the right model and
so on then from my perspective that's a
really easy part the hard part started
making the process that comes before
that in the data engineering problem
which is on where we spend 95% plus of
our time and I think that's
fundamentally a strong AI problem or
it's very tough to do but have that full
into int think in a narrow sense but I
think there's a lot of hope for things
like if your dad's coming from a
relational data base understanding that
the relational structure then
automatically creating and mapping
features based on that or identifying if
you're dealing with a stream of data
during the anomaly and out there
detection and figuring out something
changed and something's broken and then
raising that book back up to a human
reviewer and instead of having the human
reviewer need to go and investigate down
and figure out from the top level
something broke with the end result of
my model how where on earth did that
break mm-hmm I talked to a financial
institution two days ago that processes
billions of dollars of credit card
transactions and they confessed when we
went in with them that today they still
cannot resolve the total amount of
transactions that happen at Starbucks
because even the transaction logs
themselves are still so unclear
mean that they have yet to find a better
way than actually shipping all the data
to it to an overseas group that just
goes through line by line and does that
classification so kind of crazy one of
the things we also talked about I
thought would be relevant for this
audience I am keeping my eye on the
clock because we're going to open up in
about five minutes for QA what is the
question of career advice so excited a
little bit about how data engineers and
data scientists can work together my and
maybe I'll go I'll go down the the but
I'll start with you Vijay is the
possibly the most senior having worked
at the biggest organizations what do you
look for when you hire a data engineer
what are the skill sets what makes a
resume stand out for anyone heroes you
know at some point would love to work at
a sales force or Google or Microsoft so
I knew Mike was gonna ask me that
questions or like prepared for that
beforehand predictive analytic right
good job in really write what we are
doing here is large-scale system design
and this is pipeline design machine
learning data engineering they're all
same their reflections on large-scale
distributor system design and I think
the core competency that I try to hire
for sometimes unsuccessful sometimes I'm
not is hard to find out in an interview
and I wrote this down so I would repeat
it with like high fidelity the core
competency that I'm trying to hire for
in this role is making good decisions on
where complexity should live right and
this goes back earlier to to dress calls
point around it should be process at the
edge it should be process in a
centralized fashion and for example if
you're doing cheap sensors right the
data cost of transporting the sensor
data back is going to outweigh the cost
of the bond cost of putting the sensor
out in the field in the first place
right so as a results you don't want a
whole lot of like $1 chips at sending 50
$60 worth of data over their lifetime to
a centralized location because data
transport is expensive those you want to
kind of winnow down as much
you can as close to the edge as possible
because in general right cost for
transport tracks distance and then send
the aggregate results back ideally if
you are doing large-scale like for
example credit card transactions where
the the volume is relatively small but
the monetary the monetization is very
high you want to do it in a centralized
place so those are the kind of things
that I look for unfortunately they're
really hard to suss out in an interview
so so sometimes you have to take a flier
and then you have to fire fast so Sam
you're building out your team at skip
flag what you know to the extent that
you're bringing on data engineers what
what do you look for how do you what
makes a difference in a great data
engineer and a not-so-great one I mean I
agree with the v-j said that like being
able to understand where complexity
should live is really important I think
the other thing that kind of gets
overlooked is someone being very
detail-oriented especially with building
data pipelines there really is no
objective truth to know whether you have
the right data is it the right way your
sensor could be faulty your pipeline
could be faulty some of the processing
could be faulty so you're making
judgment calls and some sort of
statistical analysis or our reasoning to
figure out exactly how everything data
should flow and the and it's also the
other way too when you have some models
doing some sort of predictions you know
if you're doing that in a car at going
60 miles an hour you really need to be
able to debug that and understand that
and do that in a in a reasonable and
detailed way and then you're getting the
data in an understandable fashion okay
so you're now at Google and I assume
they're giving you a big checkbook then
to hire and build out this your group
what are you looking forward to the
extent that you're hiring folks to help
write software to crunch Adobe PDFs for
data yeah first before I touch on that I
just wanted to add on to the point about
complexity I've completely agree with
that then actually the way that we
approach our interview process at least
free Google was forgetting about looking
fair paying much attention to resumes or
have standard interview questions or
anything like that and simply throw a
complex
see data says that them with a poorly
defined objective and see how they
handled that info complexity of the
candidate and see if they managed to
control and build on that complex see
were ended up for kind of falling flat
on that and that was by far the most
effective way that we've ever
interviewed for Dow scientists or tad
engineers
nice so that's your answer is higher
look at look for people who can manage
complexity I used to have what I called
the hacker test which is I would give
people a file at the command line and
there would just be a you know gzipped
column of timestamps and I just absences
convert the you know UNIX epoch into
human readable timestamp and just wait
and watch how long it took them to do
that right and that was like if they
couldn't do that they can't be if they
can't do that in less than you know 15
minutes they are not a data engineer
right because they'll never get past the
step of unzipping the file and getting
to the data so okay so the last question
then we're going to turn over to the
audience is is really going to be about
tools kind of I think about you know all
of us have been working with tools over
the last several years I guess I would I
would sort of two-part question one is
what are some of the state old standby
tools that you rely on as
bread-and-butter anytime you have to go
in and maybe change a column of column
of strings into UNIX epoch digit and
what are some of the newer tools that
you're most excited about what new tools
have come under their eyes and in the
last you know year or so that you're
pretty excited about that could help
this next generation of data engineers
not have to do stuff the way we did and
hand roll it so I'm going to I'll
actually go and order Ben you'll start
again to put you on the spot let's see
I'll start with an old tool that I newly
discovered actually that's been a big
change in my productivity so um before I
say what that tool is how many of you
use a lot of tabs in your web browser
say if I open up your computer I see 50
different tabs open how many of you have
a similar approach to your terminal
window where your command line interface
okay maybe I love you discovered this
tool before me but there's an awesome
tool called Team X which is effectively
tabs for terminal that I got much more
productive when I could rotate a
terminal window as lightweight as chrome
tab have you ever used screen before
yeah okay so you might say is this green
on steroids and green on tears it's a
good way to put it right nice any other
tools that I need any other data tools
that you're excited about how many
people here use Dockers part of their
data pipelines right now oh well about
half the audience or so all right we
found that to be a really effective tool
to help with reproducibility and from
the habit so that 10 different people or
a thousand different people are
community you can use the same set of
Python environments that all work nicely
together instead of like having each
person who starts on the same project go
through like a head banging Day of
getting the right by their private
environment or our environment or
software environment setup Wow nice okay
so I break it down into two two
categories one is like data exploration
tools for example how do you do ad hoc
data exploration and things like Jupiter
notebooks and so on so forth are good
ones for or even Excel or G Docs or I
should say quit now I guess you can use
those for like ad-hoc writing forming
the ad hoc queries and then depending on
where you are in the spectrum right so I
look at like raw primitives which are
like assembly language of data
processing things like harun from from
Twitter or people made no storm better I
guess it's older or spark which are much
more towards the raw assembly line so
you play around with your data
exploration tools you formulate the
things you need the transforms you need
to do and then you encode them in very
low-level languages then there's stuff
that is moving more towards the
decorative side allows like Google
dataflow as implemented by Apache beam
and I think slink is implementing that
that's just really awesome we really
love the cow queen that is I think mad
well she had something to do with this
is the world will pinwheel stuff and
then after that you have decorative
truly decorative screaming decorative
stuff like screaming sequel and calcite
is an example quickstep is another
although they're planning optimizers are
terrible and I may have to rewrite some
of that stuff
but that's kind of like where you have
like you you play around with the data
you figure out the transformations and
then you encode those transformations
into systems right and then of course
you run those systems using tools like
docker containers for an kubernetes for
scheduling so you have a reproducibility
pipeline the second one which i think is
actually even more important for me is
what is actually the data right what I
need is github for data because as we
evolve our algorithms and algae evolve
our models
you can't reproduce the end results you
can debug the end results unless you run
the new model against the old data and
vice versa so you have to rev the data
models you also have to Rev data right
as I think Sam alluded very early on is
like is it the data that changed or is
it the model isn't it a bug in the data
or the model so you know you have a goal
set of data how do you like reproduce
the model and get the better results so
there's like people like pachyderm which
are actually building stuff like that
which is just completely and totally
awesome and we have our own stuff but
yeah reproducibility and versioning of
data or github for data I think is
actually a huge component that can match
data to models ok so this is the bad
part being at the end cuz I do agree
with a lot of things I haven't said here
now let me add one more which is I think
is the Python machine learning stack so
that's relatively new you have like
numpy type I so I could learn that's
change the ability to kind of get like a
baseline v-0 model what would take like
sometimes often a week before now you
can do it like 30 minutes an hour and
just set everything up with your
cross-validation and everything and get
something really quick off the ground
I'm not going to give you a very good
baseline of depending on you know your
problem space then you can decide
whether you really want to improve them
all or not but you can get something out
very fast ok so I'm now going to open it
up to the audience for some questions
and my ask will be if I will pass a
microphone around so you get a question
raise your hand we'll track you down and
you're you're welcome to direct it at
one of the panelists here I would I
didn't generally try to do is I will
like to quiet there's more than one
questions I'll take two and we'll select
one sometimes like it's a little bit of
a competition but we've got one question
here in the front and then we'll take a
second one and we'll choose the better
of the two hi you two gentlemen go ahead
alright first and just say your name and
what company you're with sure I'm mark
I'm from New Relic so this question is
directed at all three of you choose to
answer it so a lot of a lot of the
conference today has been about some
pretty advanced techniques and
architectures and a lot of them assume a
a very large well-funded data
engineering team so what advice would
you give companies that are just getting
started in building out their data
engineering and data science teams you
know what yeah just generally what
advice would you give all right we're
going to just accept that question
that's a good enough one no need for a
bake-off so then maybe whoever wants to
jump in and answer that yeah I'm happy
to because until a month and a half ago
oh it's not a large company it was a
small scrappy when the short summary was
be scrappy with how you approach
everything and be very focused on what
works for your team and specific context
so we don't spend like from a data
processing standpoint we try making
volcano status like easily available to
everyone it Kaggle and then beyond that
we don't build out a complex
architecture and a lot of what we do is
actually from an analytics perspective
if on catechol central dad's just done
in sequel or from like competition set
perspectives done within a Jupiter
notebook so we try saying like super
focus on what we need to do instead of
investing in any complex architectures
that we didn't need okay I'm gonna take
the next question here from plural light
my name is Andrea I'm from Pluralsight
okay so the question I have is you're
talking about team structure and the
question I wanted to ask is not
necessarily the team structure on
engineering but more the team structure
or the structure of the organization as
a whole to make it more data centric and
how you focus the organization as a
whole to kind of care about data and
think about data and ownership of data
you know because it's you know
oftentimes it's like oh yes this is data
engineering group over here and you're
always fighting the organizational
lateral who owns data and how to make
people care about data I'm going to make
vajay has been at a few big companies
probably fought that battle so so in
general right people I mean this is a
human cognitive system problem it's not
a organizational problem so generally
people don't want to hear answers that
clash with what they believe and so the
best way I found is that you have data
that can actually map to outcomes that
are you a be test belief against data
right and so the best way I've seen is
like okay well here's what we thought
was going to happen here's what actually
happened here's what the system
predicted would happen and then ask if
you bring charts it is hard to argue
against that if you come in and I other
thing I found is that you want to like
keep it as small as possible because
larger the set of people who are like
wrangling this decision the more
impassioned the arguments get and more
imprecise the language so you want to
keep it under few small stake key
stakeholders and try to map output of
the of the data processing or data
engineering to a business outcome is
that if you do this you will get 10
percent higher revenue or 5% more
click-through and those are pretty hard
to refute I mean you can refute them but
I mean at that point us I guess to go to
some other company and but that's that's
how typically I have approached it
mostly it works mostly ok
other than that I see someone in the way
way back here gentleman and the beard in
the bleacher seats and we've got another
if there's two microphones you get
another person right here as well yeah
but we've got so in all the way in the
back if you have another mic as well
okay you'll go I'll get you next
okay sure hi i'm paul from intermix we
help make your rich of queries 100x
faster so what engineers do you have
over what advice do you have for dane
engineers writing
unit tests to help to validate their
data without needing an external
dependency on the actual data source
alright Sam I might put you on the spot
if you if you've written unit tests for
your stuff especially now that you're
yeah startup guy so I think one of the
well let me tell you a quick story so
one of the biggest improvements we've
had at LinkedIn and one of our machine
learning models was not anything that
had to do with building a better more
sophisticated model adding new features
and like that it was basically we had an
ETL system that for whatever reason
would only put out half the table
and it was dropped the other half of the
rows anything with an odd ID with drop
we didn't realize this for like six
months that's out of fidelity the one we
did fix it it had a huge boost and I got
a nice congratulate you call from the
CEO and it was basically because we just
we didn't validate the data right it was
this is like the core problem is we just
didn't know that the data was correct
and so you can write unit tests I think
that can be helpful to make sure that
you're you what you believe is true the
problem is what you believe it may not
actually be true so you what you want to
also do is have statistical tests on the
data to know okay you know how much is
this data changing from day to day did
you know this do I have a holding set of
keys you know depending on the type of
data or of a lot more volume you can do
a lot of tests on that and that's the
way we found is to able to make sure
that the data is coming in is the same
that's coming out you're not like
accidentally dropping half the table and
throwing away all this revenue on the
table okay all the way in the back
great go ahead I imagine from Tomsk LDV
we are brand new open source data
engineering product and my question is
actually what are the most important
things you look for in did engineering
tools and what a good thing is that open
source projects can do to be most
helpful for you all right I'm just going
to get this last question is going to go
to you Ben
you're a guy who has worked at love
open-source tools and a lot of you
talked earlier about you know MATLAB
dying in Syfy numpy and are on the rise
so what what makes a great open source
data engineering tool what what can
someone is building a new open source
tool do to make their there's the choice
of the kaggle community in the future
making it super easy to use and well
documented is with like clear examples
instead of I'm going out with something
like it is X percent faster than
something else or non language that the
end user cares about instead like here's
how I use X to solve a problem for
example Francois shalay who are at the
cares package did that for a couple of
different super simple problems we have
on cackle when's the image data set for
trying machine learning or for trying a
digit recognition problem he had like
three or four examples up like that and
they that helps carrots take off like
wildfire in the community because it's
like well it's really easy to train I
can take this code and drop it into my
own problem pretty quickly then three
months later Google hired him and just
that and now Karis it's like another pop
our front-end to tensorflow
well documentation and and making a
zeroth-order step really easy okay that
that's all the time we have because I
want to make sure you guys have a chance
this is a conference after all the goal
is to confer and meet all the great
folks here that you've been hanging out
with all of us we're gonna go down and
get some drinks I think as well so we
look forward to seeing you down the
floor with drinks and thank you let's
give it a good round of applause for our
distinguished panel with Jay Benson
thanks so much guys